[Music]
English lessons today's mini English
lesson is about English being a stress
time language all languages are on a
scale from being stress time or syllable
time English is strongly stress timed
and Spanish is strongly syllable time
this means that don't pronounce every
syllable but for example it's Spanish
you do in this brand new intro music
llamo skeleton lower but in English we
only stress the important works 1 2 3 4
a 1 a 2 a 3 a 4 1001 1002 1003
then a 4 the number of words is
increased but the beach is the same
music and poetry demonstrate this really
well we all live in a yellow submarine
beginner submarine Yellow Submarine so
important words like now some verbs are
stressed and less important words are
unstressed in this form
they're called weak weak or weak forms
can be auxiliaries Gus becomes this
where does he live can becomes good what
can I do for you personal pronouns your
becomes yeah what did you boss think
prepositions o
becomes earth that's the last of the
crisps coach options then because then
she's older than you articles aa becomes
a she's a teacher
as you can see rhythm of English is very
different from French or Spanish which
has syllable tied languages I hope
you've enjoyed this video
[Music]